[Aplausos]
[Música]
puede que no nos demos cuenta pero el
mundo nuestro mundo está cambiando a
toda marcha
[Música]
biotecnología nanotecnología robótica
cada día en algún remoto lugar del
planeta se produce algún descubrimiento
o alguna patente que harán que nuestra
vida sea más fácil más larga y mucho
mejor prácticamente amigos de visual
polític podemos decir que estamos
subidos en un tren de alta velocidad
cuyo destino es el futuro
de hecho ya hay empresas increíbles
empresas por cuya actividad parecen más
propias del mundo de ciencia ficción
queréis ver algunos ejemplos pues
fijaros conocéis órgano pues es una
increíble empresa que cotiza en el
nasdaq y que se dedica ni más ni menos
que a la bio impresión de tejidos para
implantar en el cuerpo humano y evitar
así la necesidad de hacer transplantes
[Música]
os imaginais imprimir un hígado y que me
decís de mother me doy una startup que
quiere producir cuero natural y carne
sin matar a un solo animal
vamos que quieren producir sus propios
filetes en el laboratorio y llevarlos a
los supermercados la pregunta es que los
comerías bueno y otro caso habéis oído
hablar de iluminar pues es la compañía
más grande que se dedica a la secuencia
del adn entre sus objetivos está
detectar el cáncer antes siquiera de que
aparezcan los primeros síntomas
increíbles verdad
pues estos son solo tres pequeños
ejemplos de cientos y cientos de
compañías que están literalmente
construyendo el futuro pero sabéis que
esto no es lo mejor de todo sin duda
alguna lo mejor es que el fin de la
pobreza está cada vez más cerca está ya
sobre la mesa a la vuelta de la esquina
de todo esto recordaréis que ya os hablé
en este otro vídeo si no lo habéis visto
luego os dejo el enlace pero ojo no sólo
hablamos de erradicar la pobreza extrema
para nada hablamos de que en pocos años
las penurias y las calamidades que
suponen por ejemplo pasar hambre o no
poder comer carne o no tener asistencia
sanitaria o incluso no poder irse de
vacaciones van a ser una cosa rara una
cosa poco frecuente
[Música]
vale puede que muchos aquí estéis
pensando bueno a este chico alberto se
le ha ido la olla está loco tiene que
estar exagerando pues no no me he vuelto
tarumba es más aquí delante de vosotros
estoy dispuesto a apostar que en los
próximos años vamos a conocer la mayor
época de prosperidad de la historia del
ser humano y no soy el único que lo
piensa fijaros en lo que dice el genio
de la inversión fijaros en lo que dice
warren buffett
vuelvo a repetir lo que ya he dicho
otras veces y seguiré diciendo en el
futuro nuestros hijos y nietos son la
generación más afortunada de la historia
o también en lo que dice barack obama la
verdad es que si tuviéramos que elegir
cualquier momento del transcurso de la
historia humana para vivir elegiríamos
este ahora mismo pues bien amigos aún
voy a deciros más esta avalancha de
prosperidad implica oportunidades como
nunca antes hemos imaginado pero para
los que no me creáis vayamos como
siempre a los datos
y la expansión sin precedentes de la
clase media se calcula que a finales de
2016 atentos a la cifra 3200 millones de
personas pertenecían ya a la clase media
y cada año 140 millones más ingresan en
este selecto club
esto es como si cada año un país entero
como méxico dejase atrás la pobreza y
atención porque este proceso se está
acelerando hasta tal punto que en 2 o 3
años alrededor de 2020 por primera vez
en la historia del ser humano la mayor
parte de la población pertenecerá a la
clase media lo que sumado a la población
rica dejará a la pobreza en minoría y en
franco retroceso
y un momento antes de continuar seguro
que os estáis preguntando pero que se
considera como clase media como el nivel
de renta depende de cada país cuando
hablamos de clase media hablamos de
personas que pueden permitirse
económicamente pues comer una dieta
variada personas que pueden hacer frente
a imprevistos personas que pueden
acceder a comprarse un vehículo o que
por ejemplo pueden sencillamente
estudiar
[Música]
personas que en definitiva puede que no
sean ricas pero desde luego ya no son
pobres y eso es algo nuevo en la
historia de la humanidad queréis ver
cómo está cambiando el mundo fijaros en
shanghai
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y mira para que os hagáis una idea de
cómo están cambiando las cosas vamos a
hacer una perspectiva histórica cuando
napoleón guerreaba por europa en todo el
mundo poco más de 2 millones de personas
podían considerarse de clase media esto
sería equivalente a menos de la mitad de
los habitantes que hoy tiene singapur
tremendo verdad pues bien desde entonces
tuvieron que pasar 150 años para que la
clase media alcanzasen los mil millones
de personas en la década de los 70
[Música]
y ya son más de 3000 y en 2021 se espera
que lleguemos a los 4 mil millones el
proceso cada vez es más rápido y
cuidadito porque está en una clase media
viene pisando fuerte no me creéis según
la encuesta mundial de valores de 2015
las personas que forman la clase media
en los países emergentes sienten que su
éxito es consecuencia de su trabajo duro
del ahorro y de su perseverancia y en
consecuencia no apoyan las subidas de
impuestos para pagar planes sociales
como ya vimos también aquí en visual
político la población de muchos de los
países emergentes son entusiastas del
capitalismo quieren prosperar trabajando
haciendo negocios comercial
si la ciudad que estáis viendo es hanoi
la capital de vietnam el país donde más
gusta el capitalismo de todo el mundo me
parece amigos que en otros sitios nos
vamos a tener que poner un poco las
pilas por cierto todo este proceso tiene
un nombre propio asia
[Música]
la tierra de la prosperidad
casi nueve de cada diez personas que
acceden a la clase media viven en asia
el continente del despegue económico el
continente donde está el nuevo eje de
poder en la tierra solo tenéis que
fijaros en países como filipinas o
tailandia
sólo unos pocos años tendrán clases
medias tan grandes como el reino unido
francia o italia desde luego está claro
seguirán siendo países mucho más pobres
pero el crecimiento de su clase media es
sencillamente impresionante queréis ver
cómo están cambiando las cosas esto es
la carta
[Música]
y pensar en todo lo que implica para las
empresas pero eso lo vamos a ver un
poquito más tarde ahora bien de todos
los países destaca uno china cuya clase
media está literalmente explotando y es
que según las previsiones de la
consultora mckinsey si en cinco años
estas personas montas en por ejemplo la
república china de ciudadanos de clase
media sería por sí misma el tercer país
con más habitantes del mundo no está mal
verdad si queréis ver qué significan
estos cambios atentos a la ciudad de
chongching la ciudad más poblada de
china
pues bien como es lógico todas estas
personas que ahora empiezan a tener
dinerito para gastar demandan productos
de todo tipo ropa electrónica coches y
por supuesto vacaciones solo en 2016 120
millones de chinos viajaron al
extranjero y se gastaron más de 100.000
millones de dólares visitando lugares
como españa se vaya a salvar ahora ya
podéis entender por qué los países de
asia y sobre todo china son tan
importantes para las empresas
multinacionales apple invierten mil
millones de dólares en el uber chino
fijaros en el siguiente dato porque si
tenéis un negocio o estáis pensando en
montar uno puede que os interese se
estima que tan solo el crecimiento del
consumo de los chinos en los próximos
cuatro años va a ser mayor que todo lo
que consumen hoy los alemanes o los
británicos vamos que si tenéis una
empresa amigos de visual político lo
mismo os conviene en ir dándole una
vuelta al mercado asiático porque en los
próximos años van a aparecer
oportunidades como no habíamos soñado
nunca antes es una realidad me da que en
poco tiempo los cursos de chino se van a
poner bastante de moda de ovín pam pam
o bing
[Música]
consecuencias de una mayor clase media
pero las consecuencias de todo esto no
sólo significan oportunidades para hacer
pasta para los negocios la consecuencia
tal vez más importante de toda esta
expansión de la clase media
probablemente sea que tendremos
sencillamente un mundo más feliz si a
ver me explico estoy seguro de que
habéis escuchado eso de que el dinero no
da la felicidad verdad bueno pues según
las últimas investigaciones parece que
eso no es del todo cierto en 2010
angus deaton y daniel kahneman ambos
premios nobel de economía presentaron un
estudio que demostraba que hasta los 75
mil dólares anuales la felicidad y los
ingresos estaban muy correlacionados un
don al cambio de la felicidad eterna
y soy más feliz con el todo vamos que a
más ingresos más felicidad tiene sentido
al fin y al cabo con más dinero no
tienes que preocuparte de no llegar a
fin de mes de no poder comer de no poder
llevar al médico a tu familia etcétera
etcétera así que sí según las
investigaciones de estos académicos la
expansión de la clase media está dando
lugar a un mundo más feliz pero esperad
un momento porque aquí no acaba todo más
clase media suponen también personas más
formadas con más estudios más
investigadores más emprendedores en
definitiva más ideas más innovación y
por tanto más progreso el motor de
crecimiento a largo plazo es única y
exclusivamente la creación de ideas él
siempre es decir ente bien autoridades
pues bien ojo al dato hoy en china ya
hay más estudiantes universitarios que
en los mismísimos estados unidos así que
recordáis las empresas que vimos al
principio de este vídeo pues preparados
porque dentro de poco habrá muchísimas
más
[Música]
sin embargo puede que os estáis
preguntando ahora mismo pero si todo
esto es tan maravilloso como me están
contando en visual político no puede ser
que personajes como donald trump o
marine lepén tengan tanto tirón es
verdad que esta gran expansión de las
clases media se está dando a nivel
global pero no en todos y cada uno de
los sitios del mundo precisamente por
eso tenemos que tener claro que si las
economías occidentales no carburan o
tienen problemas la culpa está en casa y
no fuera oportunidades hay ahora toca
adaptarse y ser capaz de aprovecharlas
pero bueno ya sé lo que muchos estaréis
pensando esto no puede ser sostenible no
hará todo este desarrollo añicos al
medio ambiente pues no está tampoco muy
claro
sostenibilidad incluso ahí es una buena
noticia es verdad en principio más clase
media implica más consumo de todo y por
tanto más presión sobre los recursos
naturales pero también tiene otras
contrapartidas la primera es que más
clase media supone más gente en las
grandes ciudades cuyas pautas de consumo
suelen ser en general más sostenibles el
ejemplo más claro lo podemos ver en el
transporte mientras que en las ciudades
lo más frecuente es el uso de
transportes públicos en los sitios más
pequeños es todo lo contrario
más clase media también supone acelerar
la transición demográfica es decir las
mujeres hoy estudian y trabajan con lo
que se reduce el crecimiento de la
población y sobre todo más clase media
como veíamos antes supone más ideas y
más innovaciones entre ellas las que
permiten un consumo más sostenible así
que amigos miremos por donde miremos
aunque aún queda mucho por avanzar y
mejorar creo que esta vez conviene
alegrarse pero bueno y tú qué opinas
crees que estamos avanzando hacia un
mundo mejor piensas que asia puede ser
una tierra de oportunidades para hacer
negocios déjanos tu opinión en los
comentarios aquí debajo y si te ha
gustado este vídeo no dudes en ayudarnos
dándole al like y suscribirte al canal
si aún no lo has hecho por cierto si
quieres ver cómo la pobreza está
retrocediendo en todo el mundo incluido
en áfrica no te pierdas este vídeo en
que te lo cuento con todo detalle un
saludo y hasta el próximo domingo en la
vanguardia
[Aplausos]
[Música]